esta decisión se puede considerar una
estrategia de presión de Moscú
bueno primero Buenas tardes Muchas
gracias por la invitación en parte
personalmente creería que son varios
factores los que vale la pena analizar
en primer lugar
Digamos si vamos a lo más en hiato que
es la pregunta concreta vemos como Rusia
ha intentado debilitar No solo la
economía sino una infraestructura de
Ucrania y si tenemos en cuenta que la
exportación de granos es uno de los
principales fuentes de ingresos
económicos para Ucrania en este momento
la suspensión de este acuerdo puede ser
un golpe brutal para el futuro y digamos
para la situación actual que vive la
economía del país es decir digamos
viendo lo que está lo que está pasando
con los ataques contra objetivos civiles
en Ucrania este tipo de lógicas podría
grabar aún más la situación que vive
Ucrania y de esa forma digamos
debilitaron más su capacidad de
resistencia Pero por otro lado Es
evidente que de alguna forma si es
cierto lo que se demuestra Ucrania
también tendría razones para atacar la
flota porque estamos hablando de una
serie de fragatas que tienen la
capacidad de lanzar misiles crucero que
son algunas de las armas con las cuales
Rusia ha atacado la infraestructura
civil en Ucrania
Cuál es el impacto real de esta decisión
no solo para los mercados sino también
para las personas puede generarse una
escasez y una subida mayor en los
precios
eso es cierto Y de nuevo estamos ante
una situación en la cual Ucrania
justamente está terminando de recoger su
cosecha estamos hablando de que habían
más de digamos inicialmente más de 22
millones de toneladas de grano acumulado
en los puertos de Ucrania y si suponemos
que la cosecha del país en este momento
estaba llegando a unos 50 millones de
toneladas estamos hablando de un golpe
extremadamente fuerte para los mercados
de grano a nivel internacional lo que
necesariamente va a golpear no solo los
precios sino sobre todo a golpear a las
poblaciones más vulnerables y que
dependían de ese tipo de alimentos para
poder subsistir digamos en este momento
solo que además digamos no sólo un golpe
para Ucrania sino también necesariamente
será un factor que involucre a Rusia
porque Rusia también se beneficiaba de
ese acuerdo lo que significa que la
suspensión del mismo no solo va a
golpear ucranes sino también a Rusia y
su capacidad de exportar alimentos lo
cual significa que el impacto será doble
Porque tanto Ucrania como Rusia tendrán
esas limitaciones para la exportación un
asesor del presidente bolodimir selensky
aseguró que esta medida demuestra que
negociar con Rusia Es una pérdida de
tiempo podría llevar a una escalada
mayor
pues ya hemos visto en más de una
oportunidad que Rusia no ha respetado
Los acuerdos que tenían inicialmente no
invadieron cierto lo que significa que
digamos todos los acuerdos que se firman
con Rusia tienen que mirarse con mucho
cuidado y hay que tener cierto grado de
suspicacias respecto a su cumplimiento y
en cuanto a escalamiento pues ya hemos
estado ya hemos estado viendo es un
escalamiento muy significativo en las
últimas semanas de nuevo asociado sobre
todo con una decisión que ha tomado el
gobierno ruso por destruir o bueno por
por atacar a Ucrania de otra forma a
través de drones y a través de misiles
que han destruido una buena parte de la
de la infraestructura eléctrica de
Ucrania y a partir de ahí pues lo que
pueda lo que pueda aumentar como
escalada es difícil predecir
Lamentablemente hemos escuchado hablar
sobre la posibilidad del uso de una
bomba sucia y eso es como la
preocupación más inmediata en este
momento